good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation and our speaker
tonight Alan Weissman is on another case
it's he's a journalist in a sense the
science journalist
and it's been a fair amount of
journalism about the present that's
where almost all of it is there's some
journalism that's about the past most of
it is sort of archaeology or history
there's very little journalism about the
future because it doesn't exist yet and
remarkably what Weissman did he had a
book with a brilliant idea what would
happen if people suddenly weren't here
and then instead of just speculating and
talking to people who speculated he
travelled to cases of that around the
world and in a sense it is it's a it's a
classic long now piece of investigation
this is journalism about pieces of the
world that show what the whole world
might be under certain circumstances
it's really unique accomplishment please
welcome Alan Weisman
thank you thanks so much for inviting me
thanks Stuart and long now for what
you've dedicated yourselves to what I've
dedicated myself to is being a
journalist I was so curious about the
world and about everything when I was a
kid I couldn't figure out what to
specialize in journalists get to poke
their nose into everything and sometimes
live vicariously about what all the
really interesting people are doing I
have not just written about the
environment and science but over the
past couple of decades turns out that
every story ultimately is an
environmental story so what I was saying
is that as a journalist I've discovered
that nearly every story ultimately is an
environmental story we can't have our
politics and our culture and our
religions etc unless we have a planet to
stand on so as I've been covering the
environment it's taken me some of the
most beautiful places on this planet and
also some of the scariest places on the
planet and sometimes they turn out to be
one in the same you know places like
Antarctica with an invisible hole
hanging over it or the tropical forests
in our equatorial region that I'm also
there to cover the the fires and the
chainsaws and the coca cultivation and
agriculture that's bringing them down or
places like my father's homeland Ukraine
with topsoil that seems to go down
forever but also a Chernobyl disaster
you begin to understand that these
aren't disasters are not discrete events
but they're all somehow connected and
the connection comes through us so with
my privileged position of having seen so
much I decided that I wanted to write
about
fact that really in a global
environmental crisis problem though with
that to really describe something that's
going on planet wide it's got to be book
length an article just isn't gonna have
enough detail but the fact is there are
many great books about the global
environment but they're usually read by
people who already know about it or the
people who are writing them themselves
because for the rest of us I mean who
the hell wants to come back from a hard
day and kick back with something you
know a book which is a real commitment
of time a book that's basically gonna
scare the hell out of you or depress you
in think oh my god are we all gonna die
you know I certainly don't so I thought
about this for quite a while how could I
write without dumbing it down or
oversimplifying how could I write a
best-seller about the environment
something that a much wider audience
would would read and then thanks to a
suggestion from an editor who had seen
something that I had written and I
hadn't really gotten the point myself of
what it could imply it basically comes
down to this if the bottom line is a lot
of people who even though they are
impacted by the environment or they're
part of the package that is impacting
the environment don't want to read about
it because you know oh my god are we all
gonna die why don't just kill everybody
off right in the beginning and then we
don't have to worry about that anymore
but then we get to hang around through
the artifice of literature and see what
happens next and we're all kind of
suckers for the future so basically what
I did in in the book that came out of
this idea of the world without us i
dispensed with us in about a paragraph
and this is not an apocalyptic book
where you know we go down agonizingly
and drag a bunch of other species with
us or nuclear holocaust and they just
imagine enough
Minh up so that it's theoretically
possible so it's not science fiction
because lots of people won't read that
either but so remote that's probably not
gonna happen tomorrow
for example aids suppose instead of
being passed by fluids it goes airborne
and we all get it
or some evil genius figures out some way
to sterilize or sperm or lots of people
believe in the rapture so perhaps Jesus
or space aliens you know take us away
either to our heavenly chlorate or some
zoo across the galaxy but but whatever
just imagine suddenly we're gone how
would the rest of nature behave without
the constant pressures we heap on it
daily to what extent would it come in
and invade our spaces and it could it
actually wipe out all of our traces but
what would it do with some of the things
that we would leave behind you know like
everything from chemical plants to
laundromats that eventually would go off
like little time bombs and leach their
poisons into into the ecosystem or all
this carbon dioxide that we've pumped up
our chimneys and our exhaust pipes how
long would it take for that to get
reabsorbed ultimately as Stuart said I
ended up going all over the world to
find out what the answers were to people
who study this stuff to people who just
live in various kinds of environments
where they have an opportunity to
respond knowledgeably to my question of
what would happen if you weren't here
what would happen if nobody was here and
it turned out to be a very very
revealing and surprising experience but
I'm gonna take you through some of it
right now but keep this in mind
because the question that I leave
hanging right at the beginning of this
book is that since we're imagining here
what would happen in a world without us
and seeing how nature might come back is
there any way that nature's rebirth reef
flourishing might possibly include us is
there any way that we might still be a
part of the picture
well I began in a place where which I
thought was going to be extremely
strange and unfamiliar and yet I learned
something unexpected right there I'm
just going to read you a very very small
fragment you may never have heard of the
BOV aja posture but if you were raised
somewhere in the temperate swath that
crosses much of North America Japan
Korea several former Soviet republics
parts of Eastern and Western Europe
including the British Isles something
within you remembers it pushed John it's
an old polish word that means forest
primeval straddling the border between
Poland and Belarus the half million
acres of the BOV Asia busca contain
Europe's last remaining fragment of
old-growth lowland wilderness think of
that misty brooding forest that loomed
behind your eyelids when it's a child
someone read to the Grimm brothers fairy
tales and here you've got ash and linden
trees that tower nearly a hundred and
fifty feet with his huge canopies
shading a moist tangled understory of
horn beams and firm swamp all there was
fungi the size of crockery oaks shrouded
with a half a millennium of moss grows
so immense here that woodpeckers will
store spruce cones in their three inch
deep bark furrows the air is thick and
cool and draped with a silence that
parts briefly for a nutcrackers croak
pygmy owl is low whistle or
Wolfe's whale then returns to stillness
now this is a place these half-million
acres that provide for weasels and pine
martens and raccoons and badgers and
otters Fox Lynx wolves deer elk Eagles
bison European bison I had no idea until
I was there and I fifteen of them
encountered me more kinds of life were
found there than anywhere else on the
European continent except there's no
surrounding mountains or sheltering
valleys to form unique niches the BOV
has a pushed is simply a relic of what
once stretched West Siberia or East to
Siberia and West to Ireland now the
existence in Europe of such a legacy of
unbroken biological antiquity and
surprisingly owes to high privilege
during the 14th century a Lithuanian
Duke marry the queen of Poland became
King and named this places royal hunting
preserve a succession of Polish kings
and then Russian Czars after them kept
it that way things got a little
convulsive in the 20th century after
World War one
Poland named at National Park but then
in came the Soviets and they started
logging in there but then oddly enough
to the rescue came the Nazis the guy
named Hermann Goering great lover of
life
like like those Royals before him you
know named it a preserve only for him
and his buddies and and kept it that way
at the end of World War two the polish
scientist who took me into this place
explained that some of their
predecessors apparently got just a
Stalin really drunk in Warsaw and
convinced them that it should be a
national park so that's as it remains
today now obviously it's amazing to
think that all Europe once look like
this place but the reason that I wanted
to tell you about it is that to enter it
is to realize that most of us were bred
to a pale copy of what nature intended
because when you see these alters of
trunks that are seven feet wide but you
walk through stands of the tallest trees
which are the gigantic Norway spruce
that are Shaggy's Methuselah you think
that would seem as exotic as the Amazon
to those of us who were raised among the
comparatively puny second growth
woodlands found throughout the northern
hemisphere but instead what's
astonishing is how primarily familiar it
feels and then some cellular level how
complete you go in there and you see
these giant versions of the trees that
most of us from the northern hemisphere
have grown up around and your body's
going yes Wow but being home and I
really do believe that on some level our
bodies do remember when I started
working on this thing people would say
so what are you writing these days and I
said well I'm researching a book on what
the world would be like without people
in it the overwhelming response I got
from about 90% of the people was God
does that sound great
and then they would inevitably reflect
than what they had just said and and the
next reaction was yeah but I mean I mean
wouldn't it be a shame that in order for
the world to come to full flower we
would have to go I mean you know we're
not so bad we've done some beautiful
things too and and and the more I heard
this I realized this is really what I
needed to be writing about the fact that
there's something in us that senses that
we had something really wonderful and
that we've somehow lost it and we want
it back
no only after I finished this book did I
realize I'm not the first author let's
come up with a scenario some of you know
this book Genesis where we start in
paradise and then we blow it and then
the rest of the book and its sequel are
how do we get back to it you know how
that one ends or though that last
chapters a doozy it's you got to read a
lot of times and it's still confusing
but let me tell you where this one goes
I mean one of the things that I had that
I literally had to do was figure out why
I just had to tear down the walls that
we have erected between us and the rest
of nature just to get a sense of how
we've become so dissociated so I'm just
gonna read you one more small fragment
and the day after humans disappear
nature takes over and immediately begins
cleaning house our houses that is cleans
them right off the face of the earth
they all go now if your homeowner you
already knew it was only a matter of
time for yours
but you've resisted admitting it even as
erosion callously attacked starting with
your savings because back when they told
you what your house would cost nobody
mentioned what you'd also be paying so
that nature wouldn't repossess it long
before the bank even if you live in a
denatured postmodern subdivision where
heavy machines mash the landscape into
submission replacing unruly native flora
with obedience sod and uniform sapling
is paving wetlands in the righteous name
of mosquito control even then you know
that nature wasn't fazed because no
matter how hermetically you've sealed
your temperature tuned interior from the
weather invisible spores penetrate
anyway which is awful when you see it
you guys I explode and these sudden
outbursts of mold and worse when you
don't because it's hidden behind a
painted wall and it's munching paper
sandwiches of gypsum board and rotting
studs or floor joists or you've been
colonized by termites carpenter ants
roaches Hornets small mammals but most
of all though you are beset by and what
other context is the veritable stuff of
life water it always wants in and I go
into a discussion here that those of you
who have a roof with a warranty know
that that warranty never counts around
the chimney or the skylights and
eventually water gets underneath and if
we're not there to do something
expensive all kinds of things start to
happen really quickly and that's even if
you're using some of these newer
materials you know like these bonded
resin substitutes for plywood that are
all these little timber flakes and all
that or Hardy planks or all these things
turns out that newer isn't necessarily
better Verna von Braun the German
scientist who developed the u.s. space
program used to tell this story about
Colonel John Glenn the first American to
orbit the Earth
he says seconds before liftoff with
Glenn strapped into that rocket that we
built for him and man's best efforts all
focused on that moment you know what he
said to himself oh my god I'm sitting on
a pile of low bids
[Applause]
well well most of us are in most of our
homes and buildings were sitting under
them and and in some ways okay you know
we're using fewer resources by building
things out of you know cheaper materials
or stuff that we glue together because
those old big Timbers for posts and
beams most of them are gone
but as I discovered in many different
venues all over this world is that the
stuff that is built for you know the
lowest possible bid that legality will
allow ends up being the fastest to come
down I'm not gonna go into all the gory
detail here that I do in this book it's
briefly it's a mercifully brief chapter
but but suffice it to say that if you
have a very old house that's built out
of big stones chances are that's gonna
last longer than most of what we're
building right now without us around to
maintain these things within a century
an abandoned house as the water gets in
there and the nail hole interest to the
nail holes and they rust and they start
losing their grip and pretty soon the
roofs start shifting and the walls start
most of the stuffs come in lying on the
ground with it within a century or it's
gonna be leaning pretty badly masonry
houses of course will last longer but
the mortar is already going to be
crumbling and the bricks are going to be
dropping the things that last the
longest
your bathroom tile might be on the
ground but it's chemically very close to
being a fossil and as long as something
doesn't crush it it's gonna be there for
a long time
stainless steel if it's buried away from
oxygen might have a few hundred thousand
years in it but ultimately all these
materials that we have through some
technology kicked up into a higher
energy state find their way back to it
now it's one thing to imagine a house
coming down
but what about these enormous cities and
such as the one that we're in aid the
infrastructure seems so impressive so
overwhelming that it's very hard to
imagine something made out of as much
concrete and steel as say Manhattan ever
reverting to a forest the way it was
when Henry Hudson first saw it in 1609
with just a few Native Americans living
around the the perimeter so that was the
question that I put when I went there I
chose it because it's the universal city
everybody's either been there or they've
seen it in films and it's the
quintessence of artificiality and I and
I talked to architects urban planners
civil engineers mechanical engineers
maintenance personnel from bridges and
tunnels and but and botanists and
biologists and a hundred percent of them
said not only could it revert to a
forest but it absolutely will someday it
was demonstrated to me rather
graphically how this would happen by
subway maintenance personnel who took me
down through the bowels of Manhattan in
Brooklyn and showed me what they have to
contend with which is basically the
underside of fairly recent history until
the 19th century Manhattan still looked
like what that name which was an old
Algonquin term meant which was hilly and
the hills that made up Manhattan Island
were all drained by about 40 streams and
rivers that ran between them in yeah
well just to give you an idea of what it
looked like where the Plaza Hotel is
today at South End of Central Park that
was a big long lake shallow attached to
a salt marsh that ran to the East River
to the west of that was a big ridge line
one of the highest places on the island
it was sort of a deer and mountain lion
path
and it had streams going off to the
Hudson or again to the East River today
we call that broad ridge line Broadway
but it's no longer elevated because in
the 19th century everything north of
Greenwich Village got flattened down to
superimpose a grid of streets on it
so all those streams and rivers got
buried and though a sewer system was put
in basically to imitate the way that
nature used to wick water away we never
quite do it as efficiently as nature
does so what the subway engineer showed
me is that along with the normal
groundwater that a rainy climate like
New York gets they're dealing with these
buried rivers and they have to keep 800
pumps : nearly all constantly to pump
away even on a sunny day thirteen
million gallons of water that's trying
to flood the system and I said so what
happens when you guys aren't here or
what would happen if nobody was here and
you know the power companies stopped
delivering power to the pumps well
they've had to deal with those
emergencies a lot in power failures and
they end up bringing trucks with
diesel-powered compressors that runs
hoses down the the subway steps to pump
stuff away but if nobody ever came back
within 36 hours the subways would be
flooded and if they didn't show up then
to drain them things would get
waterlogged and the steel foundations of
skyscrapers in New York which are
anchored to the Manhattan schist they
were not intended to be waterlogged
they would become destabilized come
along a hurricane New York's had in
before and it'll have more of them in
the future it looks like a destabilized
building when it falls it's sort of like
when a tree crashes in the forest it
brings down more with it but even long
before that just the columns holding up
the plat the ceiling when you're
standing in a subway platform
was known as the street those columns
within 20 years would be buckling and
caving in and the streets above them and
then there'd be rivers on the surface of
Manhattan again and then something
really amazing would happen very quickly
they would spring to life birds there'd
be a lot more birds I have a whole
chapter on birds in this book many
things happen to them what with us here
such as just in the United States alone
75 million of them end up on our
windshields or our radiator grills so
add 75 more birds back into the into the
picture they'd be dropping herring and
clams which also would be proliferating
again in the harbors and the rivers and
and stuff would fall into these into
these you know where the four five six
line is that would now be the Lexington
river you know in a miraculous stuff
would come to life it turns out that
wherever I went for this book any place
where humans turn their backs life other
kinds of life appears and begins to
proliferate at one point I'm with this
guy who has it was in charge of three of
the biggest bridges that connect
Manhattan to the mainland and he said
you know it's it's incredible you can't
think of it's hard to think of something
more sterile than the intersection of
two two-inch thick steel plates he says
but every time we turn our back some
bird flies over poops out a seed and the
next thing we know there's this
Ailanthus tree whose roots are tearing
apart the George Washington Bridge he
says one way or another he says you know
we are in a battle against nature a
constant battle which ultimately we are
gonna lose this is my job is that it
doesn't happen on my watch
well in the streets meantime there'd be
no personnel who would be cling clearing
out the plants that show up in the
cracks in the sidewalk every spring from
seeds that are constantly blowing
through the city and they'll start to
tear apart the sidewalks nobody would be
unclogging the sewers an innumerable
number of plastic bags would have them
clogged they'd be filling up with leaf
litter plants would be germinating there
they'd they the roots would go right
through the asphalt you would start to
get saplings growing in the streets
there'd be no firemen so finally when a
lightning strike hits something some
dead branches or whatever there's gonna
be a fire and then you're gonna have
insulation burning in adjacent buildings
because every building superintendent
told me just like as I mentioned before
your houses on the roof particularly
these flat roof buildings water
eventually leaks in and if you're not
stopping that that steel reinforcing bar
the steel the rust will begin to form
and it expands and it pops facing off
this insulation that will be exposed
that will burn papers and the offices
will burn that's good because it will
add carbon to the soil so the first
plants that come in will be kind of
acidic tolerant but now more kinds of
species will be able to enter and
eventually within within 500 years New
York is basically going to be a forest
again growing up through the ruins of
buildings the oldest buildings again
the ones made out of the stuff of
Manhattan itself st. Paul's Chapel right
across from the World Trade Center made
out of Manhattan shifts first building
there I'll probably be the last it
didn't even budge when those planes hit
bank vaults will probably last longer
but even when the banks are gone but
mainly you're gonna have a forest
growing up and by the way this happens
in arid climates too
one point in this book I go to the
island of Cyprus during the early 1970s
Greek Cypriot money built a beach resort
on the eastern side the side that faces
Syria just like an Acapulco it's about
five kilometers of tall hotels
reinforced steel reinforced concrete
structures with balconies hanging over
the sea and then unfortunately a couple
years later war broke out in Cyprus when
the UN brokered a truce the two sides it
was the Greek Cypriots and the Turkish
Cypriots the Turkish Cypriots were given
the north and the Greek Cypriots the
south and this thing ended up in Turkish
Cypriot territory
well the Turks very intelligently
realized that this valuable piece of
real estate would be a great bargaining
chip when the island got around to
reunification talks so instead of
letting people go in there and
colonizers just put a fence around it
sadly enough 30-some years later
this has not been resolved and this big
resort is still behind this now rusting
fence every building in there I mean
very few people have gone in there I was
fortunate to get some glimpses myself
and be taken in and to talk to several
people who have who have seen all of it
the building the hotels are now occupied
but they're occupied by rats and by
pigeons and all stuff and they bring in
fruit and then they poop out of sea the
next thing you know you've got trees
growing right out the roof and the
windows the hotel lobbies are filled
with sand dunes
there are vines growing across the
streets even though this is an arid
climate wildflower cyclamen have pushed
their way straight up through concrete
streets you see fields of flowers now in
the middle of the streets the only thing
none of these buildings and they're only
30-some years old is salvageable anymore
they would all have to be bulldozed the
only thing that looks really great still
is the beach it's in fine shape and it
is being used by an awful lot of sea
turtles well in Manhattan I wanted to
know if this thing reverts to a forest
would it be the same forest that was
there when Henry Hudson when Henry
Hudson saw it and it turns out no it
won't be for a couple of reasons some of
it yes there will be some native species
though with climate change you know we
don't know whether the native species
will end up being Paul meadows and
magnolia trees coming up from the south
it's hard to say but right now you can
go to New York Botanical Garden which is
right across from the Bronx Zoo some of
you have been there there's a 40 acre
plot of old-growth uncut New England
forests there except nothing of the
original species like Oaks and hickories
and in beaches have regenerated in the
last 80 years partly because there have
been so many industrial and automobile
fumes etc that these trees have been
weakened and they can't fight off a lot
of the opportunity to NIST is 'yes' or
insects that are coming and the other
reason is that being the only patch of
green that you know four miles
surrounded by all this concrete grey
Bronx every squirrel in the Bronx now
lives there and they eat all the hickory
nuts and acorns before they have a
chance to germinate what is growing
there though very well
stuff that squirrels were not adapted to
to eat and that is the fruit of things
that have blown in ornamental plants
like again Chinese Ailanthus
trees cork trees wax berry trees a lot
of these oriental ornamentals that now
are more than half the plants growing in
this original forest and the botanist
who took me out there guy named Chuck
Peter says you know everybody wants me
to put the forest back the way it was
200 years ago I say you know put the
Bronx back the way it was 200 years ago
maybe we have a chance but he said look
he said think of it this way you know
it might not be so bad what we have here
first of all what makes New York a great
city is its cultural diversity you know
everybody has something to offer but
botanically we get so xenophobic we love
native species and we want all these
exotics to go back where they came from
and he said look this might sound
blasphemous but maintaining native
biodiversity is less important than
maintaining a functioning ecosystem what
matters is that soil gets protected that
water gets clean that trees filtered the
air and that a canopy regenerates new
seedlings to keep nutrients from
draining away down the river now this is
a guy who has spent his career going to
forests all over the world and his
research has revealed to him that when
he runs into a grove of wild palm nuts
like Brazil nuts deep in the Amazon or
durian fruit trees in virgin Borneo or
tea trees in Burma's jungles those
aren't accidents once humans were there
too the wilderness swallowed them in
their memory but its shape still bears
their echo as will our forests which in
some ways is a comforting thought I got
an opportunity to see some of these
places that we have changed so much and
to see how nature eventually does smooth
out our edges one of the most dramatic
places I went was to the Korean
Demilitarized Zone which as most of you
know in a 57 years ago was this battle
ravage piece of scorched earth
that became a buffer zone between two
warring sides that were basically
carrying out a hot surrogate war of the
Cold War communist North Korea into the
South I guess our Korea at the time
nobody imagined that this piece of land
which is it's about 150 miles long it
bisects the Korean Peninsula and
two-and-a-half miles four kilometers
wide no one imagined that 50 some years
later it would still be a no-man's land
what they really didn't imagine was that
this rather scarred territory would in
just half a century revert to wilderness
so quickly that today it's accidentally
one of the most important wildlife
refuges in all of Asia home to some of
the most endangered species on the
continent at one point when I was there
and I went in with some Korean
scientists who had access and we're
standing up on a promontory at a at a
military station which every in a few
kilometers or so they're these big gun
placements where the South Koreans are
pointing their weapons at the North
Koreans or pointing them right back and
[Music]
to the biggest most hostile armies in
the world are lined up along this thing
in pointing guns screaming obscenities
at each other through loudspeakers and
in the midst of this ornithologist
points to me a point manure west and
directs me to look at what I thought was
a squadron of fighter planes coming in
until as they came closer I realized I
was looking at one of the rarest sights
on earth the red-crowned crane which
next to the whooping crane is the rarest
is maybe 1,500 of them left
most of them winter in the Korean DMZ
and in the midst of all these seething
hostilities these things come gliding in
and this is a bird that even though it's
so rare you've all seen this thing
because it's it's got a cherry cap and
black extremities and the rest of it is
just sort of white and pure as innocence
itself it's you see it continually in
Chinese painting and Japanese art and
Korean silks it's like a mythical bird
of the Orient it refers to longevity and
luck and they see just silently glide in
and they settle down and they're light
enough that they don't touch off the
landmines and and in it and they feed on
this restored wilderness and there's
juveniles so they're breeding I mean
it's just for a writer it's like being
in the middle of a metaphor to watch
this thing you know the Korean
scientists I was with none of them would
admit to praying against peace but in
fact if it weren't for this suspended
state of war between the two Koreas
you've got 20 million people in South
Maasai's of Seoul or banging up against
the south side of the DMZ and North
Korea's building industrial parks and
the developers have their crosshairs on
this thing I mean they would love to get
it and it would be a negligible cost to
them to sweep away the minds in terms of
what this real estate is worth unless as
these scientists and scientists all over
the world including in this country I've
been trying to convince the two Koreas
to do a wonderful thing for the
ecosystem and for the world to declare
this place an International Peace Park
which would be the salvation of a lot of
creatures of course if there were no
people left on earth then the whole
Korean Peninsula would be a Peace Park
effect so with the whole planet I guess
but
so well I'll let you draw your
conclusions from that one of the things
that I was interested in is what
materials have we created what would be
the longest lasting and at one point I
go down to a melange get that's even
more artificial than Manhattan in you've
all seen fragments of this but the
longest one on earth is the one that I
went to which stretches from Houston
down along its shift channel to
Galveston I refer to it as a petrol
escape and you know it's just this just
continuous line of pipelines and storage
tanks and cracking towers and flares and
just all this petroleum infrastructure
and it was really kind of fun talking to
both people in the petroleum industry in
Texas ecologists is - you know this
stuff is not that old
it's barely over a century you know how
long would it what used to be here
before and how long would this stuff
last it turns out it wouldn't last all
that long if we were to disappear even
though it looks so formidable
hydrocarbons crude petroleum this stuff
is pretty it's pretty aggressive and
corrosive and they constantly have to
replace parts the the maximum lifespan
for anything down there is about 20
years and if no one's there painting it
you know it's going to start to crumble
and it's going to start to to corrode
really fast in fact well I never overtly
come out and say it in this book but
it's it's a subtext that follows so much
of it that it's been pointed out to me
it's one of the reasons why this book
I'm grateful to say did become the
bestseller I want you know I hope that
it would and
in fact it's out in 33 languages now but
but even in this country I haven't just
been on NPR shows Minh a lot of
conservative talk shows and one of the
reasons that conservative talk shows
seem to like it well one they say is you
know this guy's not some environmental
it's making us feel guilty just shows
you all this interesting stuff and let
you decide for yourself but also I mean
there's a subtext that you know I
interviewed hundreds of people's for
this book it turns out I never
interviewed any politicians that wasn't
by intention but they don't have much to
do with holding together Society you
know I mean if they disappeared
you know I'd keep writing we'd keep
trading you know you know life would go
on but you get rid of the maintenance
personnel the people who keep our
subways pump to keep our bridges and our
bridges painted so they don't start
popping rivets and drop which is what
would happen rather quickly or show up
to keep make sure that our power plants
don't explode you know be they be they
coal-fired or petroleum or or whatever
you get rid of them everything collapses
they're really the unsung heroes of of
our society and certainly of my book and
you know in a lot of conservative talk
shows you know realize that you know
this is part of their audience and and
we really have to appreciate those
people because they are the bedrock upon
which our society stands so anyhow the
what would happen without them is
depending on how fast
if someone banked the fires before the
thing exploded before all humans
disappeared if they did that then the
stuff would just sort of gunk up and
then all that steel would corrode fairly
quickly and then we'd have a real mess
meaning that all that oil and stuff
that's inside all all those things would
end up in the Gulf of Mexico which we
be a pretty yucky oil spill except
that's by our frame of reference and our
time frame nature's got microbes that
knows what to do with crude petroleum
and though it would take a long time a
thousand years or more nature's got all
the time in the world and that stuff
would get eaten and it would eventually
you know eventually you'd have a
bottomland forest as you did before what
wouldn't go away so quickly though is
something that in recent years we
started to derive from these
hydrocarbons recent years be in the last
century many forms of it we know them
collectively as plastic as a plastic
expert explained to me the it's sort of
like when the first tree trunks appeared
on the planet the first trees made out
of lignin and cellulose microbes didn't
have the enzymes to break down the
lignin they weren't all that good with
cellulose yet either so they the first
trees would just sort of lie there on
the ground
they wouldn't decay and eventually a lot
of them got buried and so much pressure
on them that that they turned into much
of what we call the Carboniferous layer
today so plastic even though eventually
microbes are gonna figure out since
we've made billions of pounds of the
stuff that there's a feast to be had
they will develop the enzymes to break
it down it may take a hundred thousand
years or more and meantime most of the
plastic that's except for what's been
incinerated is still around and you know
we know again in geologic time that
ultimately everything the Himalayas
Sierra Nevadas they all wash to the sea
but we can't put our minds around that
in our lifetime
because plastic weighs a lot less than
rocks it turns out that plastic is not
just hanging out in our landfills it
blows down our gutters and
and winds and streams and it turns out
that much of it is going to the sea at
one point in this book I go to where
there are these huge floating rafts of
plastic on the oceans the size of small
continents and even though plastic you
can break those polymers and break it
into smaller pieces of plastic sunlight
will do that you know on plastic
sheeting you leave out in the ocean
stuff is breaking down into smaller and
smaller pieces of plastic and that's
getting either filtered or mistaken for
food by smaller and smaller creatures
it's now no longer just some seabirds
and sea turtles dying of constipation
with four or five pounds of plastic and
they're got but it's tough all the way
down to the sizes Oh plankton what the
environmental impact of this will be we
have no idea
this is one of the unintended
consequences of something technological
that we did you know the idea of
something light and durable was seemed
like a good idea but it now turns out
that it has kind of a dark side
something else that I looked at was
radioactive materials I was interested
in you know nuclear wastes stuff that's
in our nuclear plants depleted uranium
has a pretty long half-life about the
life of the planet actually so that
means that as a human-made artifact that
see around probably till the end of
Earth itself it's also interesting that
you know as the stuff piles up and we
don't know what to do with it recently
we've discovered something to do with it
it's so dense that they're making it
into projectile points and because
they're armor-piercing I mean your tax
dollars in mine are using them in a
couple of wars right now and we're not
the only nation that
that does this but if you think about
how much we know about prehistory in
North America comes from projectile
points you know that Clovis people etc
and I think of the archaeologist of the
future you know I hope they understand
these things might be a little bit too
hot to handle but of course you know
it's it's hard to warn them the nuclear
plants themselves at one point I go to
Palo Verde which is our newest nuclear
plant in the United States it takes
2,000 people to run the thing and so I
said so what happens when nobody's here
if everybody disappeared and they said
well you know the plant automatically
shuts down because there's you know
failsafe mechanisms and they said but I
just toured the the reactors and you
have to keep water circulating around
the reactor to cool it I said you know
the plant shuts down what's gonna keep
the water circulating they said well
we've got emergency generators what do
they run on diesel how much you got a
week's worth well as long as somebody
shows up maintenance personnel again to
fix the reactor no problem but someday
we're not gonna be there and he'd every
species ultimately dies goes extinct the
same way as every human you know
eventually dies and unless we figured
out some way to decommission these
things what's gonna happen is that four
hundred and forty plus nuclear reactors
in the world that are water-cooled and
many of them with actually multiple
reactors the heat from the reactor core
will take that water that's no longer
circulating and it will evaporate it and
then depending on how much fuel is in it
where it is in its feeling cycle either
you're gonna have a big radioactive fire
or you're gonna get a meltdown
and that'll be an interesting challenge
for nature to deal with 440 Chernobyl's
now Chernobyl itself is a pretty
interesting site is I think a lot of you
probably you know probably know when I
went there seven years after the rear
the reactor disaster already nesting
swallows were around it but a lot of the
fledglings were they had these albino
flake flecks on them and they weren't
returning from migration which either
meant that they were more attractive to
predators or they were just too weak
stuff was happening and there now have
been more biological studies two of the
guys Chester and Baker both American
scientists or manat long ago on
ukrainian television and they said is
how would you characterize the impact of
the Chernobyl disaster and the Ukrainian
environment and they said oh it's the
best thing that ever happened to it
basically there's this 30 kilometer
radius evacuated zone around it and
where human beings aren't wildlife
rushes in so it's now the most
biodiverse spot in all of Ukraine which
is great until you turn on a Geiger
counter and you realize that there's
some problems here but it looks fabulous
I mean there's the hedges that used to
be neat landscaping around houses are
now over growing the roofs and and moss
is covering the roads and
and trees roots or break and everything
up what really is interesting to me
though is that there has been some
studies on voles these little there's
little mice and in the most recent ones
ones that have come out in the past
couple of years it's confirmed that like
these swallows and other other animals
that they studied that there is genetic
damage and they're living abbreviated
lifestyles but they seem to be sexually
maturing earlier and having bigger
broods which means that Nature has
figured out a way to respond to a sudden
dramatic change in the ecosystem by just
throwing out more possibilities that
something will either through a mutation
or recessive gene will will develop some
kind of resistance to this latest change
in the ecosystem and so maybe the way
that Evoque voles are going to evolve in
a more radioactive environment is if
these turn out to be successful will be
these more radiation tolerant creatures
it turns out that life has been doing
this kind of stuff ever since it
appeared on the planet at one point I
interview a scientist from the
Smithsonian Doug Irwin is one of the
world's extinction experts and as many
of you know you know the earth has gone
through some enormous extinctions even
before humans showed up cataclysms where
well the Permian extinction is the
granddaddy of them all 252 years ago
there was a volcanic eruption and what
today's Siberia it lasted about a
million years and all this stuff came up
right through the Carboniferous layer so
talk about global warming I mean this is
fire and brimstone and apparently at the
same time
an asteroid hits Antarctica and when the
dust settles from all this
90% of all life-forms on earth are gone
I mean this place is devastated the only
vertebrate left is this little tooth
worm our ancestor but you know
eventually you know it crawls back onto
the land and there's a few weeds that
are growing and they're pretty scraggly
but as they die they lay down some
biological material which creates a
little soil and it takes millions and
millions and millions of years but
finally the earth is this fabulous
jungle incredibly lush with these
enormous reptiles that are incredibly
successful for over a hundred million
years and it's just sensational until
this other asteroid hits what is today
the Yucatan Peninsula kicks up a cloud
of dust that kills off about 60% of
everything alive including those big
reptiles but then this rather minor
character in the age of dinosaurs sees
this empty niche and a chance to expand
into it and here we mammals are well
what about us you know in this book I
don't just talk about ugly things that
we've left behind there's some beautiful
stuff that we have done on this planet
it's nice to know that bronze is even
more resilient than plastic and that
Rodin sculptures are going to last much
longer than probably we will but again
that's kind of geologic time and at one
point I interview an artist to Carl
Sagan and Frank Drake hired - his name
is John Lomborg to put together this
package of sounds and images and in size
them on a gold-plated copper record
append them to the Viking spacecraft
that left earth in the late 70s to tour
the outer planets and now they're off in
interstellar space had it you know for
over a billion years easily they will be
carrying with them the
sounds of indigenous people's chance and
Louis Armstrong's music and the queen of
the Nights aria from the Magic Flute in
which the highest note in the operatic
repertoire is reached kind of a symbol
of how far we can reach and it's sort of
deeply satisfying to realize that long
after we're gone that this stuff will
still be out there
but again that's geologic time what
about the earth as we know it with us in
it well I got an idea when I interviewed
a guy who's head of something called the
voluntary human extinction movement you
know basically this guy's premise and
it's in its it's not too different from
several ecologists who you know we all
know of he felt that okay you know the
human race was a good idea for a while
but now there's so many of us and we go
so far and we dig so deep and we you
know harvest so much that we're
literally you know we're rejiggering the
planet you know the chemistry of the
land and the water and the atmosphere
itself and we're pushing so many species
off the planet someday we're gonna maybe
we're gonna push one too many something
that we didn't know we depended on until
it was too late so why not he says just
admit it okay it was great for a while
but now it's it clearly not working and
let's just stop procreating and just go
gracefully and he's to think of it he
said every decade as there'd be fewer
and fewer people left the world we come
Wilder more beautiful and more natural
until the very last people would see it
was be like the Garden of Eden all over
again which was really kind of a
disturbing thought because in a sense
you know was the premise of my book the
world without us you know how nature
could restore itself but that when he
said it that way I mean it really made
me understand deeply that I was not
right in this book because I think the
world will be better off with
but because I wanted to theoretically
wipe us off the planet long enough so we
could see how resilient and literally
awesome life is and in creative and and
how it could restore and refill empty
niches in the figure isn't there some
way that we can be part of this picture
too and I really do believe that we
deserve to be here as much as any other
species that has made it this far but he
has a point so you know we have gotten a
little bit oppressive so I decided I
ended up doing something at the end of
this book that I didn't plan to do which
was basically another thought experiment
in which I wanted to find out is there a
way is there some compromise between
what he was saying no more people being
born and what we're doing right now
which I had to investigate and I found
out that well what it comes down to is
that every four days there's a million
more people on the planet which does not
sound like a very sustainable figure it
turns at the beginning of the 20th
century there were 1.8 billion people
and then in the last century our numbers
doubled and they nearly redoubled again
now for several reasons that I'll
discuss in a minute that rate has slowed
down but it's a little bit like slamming
the barn door after the horses are
already out because so many people on
this planet are so young and they have
yet to come into their breeding years
that even if they are having fewer
children than their predecessors their
parents have they're still gonna push us
from where we are right now which is at
6.8 billion to an estimated nine billion
give or take a half a billion by
the middle of this century now that's
50% more of us emitting carbon dioxide
requiring food so the new thought
experiment I ended up doing was setting
social issues aside at attendance social
issues aside for the moment what if we
all starting tomorrow did the Chinese
experiment of one child per family well
I called the zero population or I tried
to call the zero population growth
movement which used to be big in the 70s
I couldn't find them it turns out no
they didn't depopulate themselves out of
existence but but they did rename
themselves I didn't find out what that
new name was until after I was done with
the book but because during the 1980s
the whole issue of population became
explosively sensitive from attacks both
from the left-wing and from the
right-wing from the left-wing part of it
was a women's rights issue women felt
that they didn't want governments
telling them what to do with their
reproductive rights which is certainly
an understandable position also poor
countries third world countries as they
were called their biggest strength was
in manpower and they didn't want
suddenly mandates coming from some rich
countries telling them you know okay
you're gonna have to weaken yourselves
now for the good of the whole planet
from the right wing well the best
articulation of this is in 1984 world
population conference Mexico City which
then was the biggest city on the planet
our representative this was under the
Reagan administration James Buckley
William F's brother announced that the
United States was pulling its plug on
financing family planning programs
throughout the world through the UN for
two reasons one was that the money might
end up going to abortion
but the second he was very frank that he
said the United States likes big
populations because the more people out
there the more consumers there are for
the products of capitalism well I found
a demographics Institute at the Austrian
Academy of Science that ran some numbers
for me and they were quite surprised at
what they found remember one point eight
billion at the beginning of the 20th
century now we're at 6.8 billion they
found that if we all went to one child
per family within a century we'd be back
down to 1.8 billion now that's a very
interesting number one point a billion
would leave a lot of room for other
species might bias a lot of time on this
planet to learn how to deal with some of
the problems that we have caused it's
also is a very uncomfortable thought I
mean I'm the second child in my family
you know a lot of us have siblings who
we love the whole idea of big families
are already beautiful and also it seems
just impossible I mean we're organisms
were designed to make copies of
ourselves and we have religions that
tell us to be fruitful and also lately I
mean some believe that the problem is
taking care of itself as I mentioned the
rate of fertility is really dropping and
there's been a lot of recent books
there's an article just last month in a
Foreign Affairs quarterly that suggests
that it's taking care of itself because
as the world becomes more urban and in
50% of us now live in cities there's
need fewer needs for children you know
you don't need them to help tend the
flocks or the fields there's also some
proof which I've discovered that in
places you know it seemed really
unlikely that population rates are
coming down even faster than in China
with its draconian measure it turns out
that talk about unlikely I mean comes
into everybody's mind you know
not gonna let this happen but in three
of the world's most Catholic countries
Ireland Spain and Italy their population
rate is down to its close to like one
child per family it's about 1.2 why
education female education particularly
Italy has one of the highest percentages
if not the highest percentage of female
PhDs
women who stay in school defer their
childbearing years and then they have
fewer children because they've got
something else interesting and important
to do with their life there is a fear
right now in Europe about well with all
these countries shrinking in these
immigrants coming in that all of Europe
is going to be a Muslim country by the
year 2040 I mean there's a lot of
frankly hate literature about this right
now but there is you know there's no
question that immigrants are you know
from poor countries have traditionally
higher you know higher percentages of
children and their families at least for
the first generation but there are
examples like Iran we can call this an
Islamic Republic after the Ayatollah
Khomeini took over in 1979 be fruitful
multiply build us a mighty nation in
Iran had one of the highest population
growth rates in history but 10 years
later when he died in the current
Ayatollah ha many came in he and some of
the people around him realize this was
problem so they didn't do anything
draconian like China they just did a
patriotic campaign including a fatwa
saying that it might be okay
to have a vasectomy if you have enough
children and they made birth control of
all kinds from condoms up to tubal
ligations and vasectomies free and
accessible to everybody in the country
and now it's pretty much the model
program in the world for family planning
most families are between one and two
kids
that combined with opening the
universities to women
which unfortunately the current
President Ahmadinejad is trying to close
down tell the women get out of the
classroom go home and have babies
anybody wonder why'd those protests in
the streets of Tehran have been mainly
female well the books and articles that
have been coming out talking about
catastrophic population crashes now
refer to some very difficult issues
aging population smaller labor pools
fewer consumers for goods there is
advice now that the US and Europe should
start providing incentives to have for
families to have more babies because and
I'm quoting from one of them lest of
markets collapse like a Ponzi scheme
because of course Ponzi scheme always
need more consumers to you know to fill
in at the end well what I think that
these books and articles are missing is
that we're not the only species on the
planet and that we may already be it's
not just a question of slowing down our
rate but that we may already be too many
and that it's not just a matter of
slowing down but it's bringing our
numbers back into some kind of
equilibrium or harmony with the rest of
nature as opposed to mortal combat with
it
there were there's some things that we
can do some of you who have read Stewart
brand's new book he does a magnificent
job of laying out some of the things
that we might be doing to face a future
in which we're definitely going to have
to take charge some technological things
that right now are going to be you know
it's going to take an enormous amount of
ingenuity the reason I put population
control as one of the things that we
should be thinking of is simply this it
doesn't take any technological leaps we
already know how to do
this family planning has has worked in
the past and even though the idea seems
so unnatural we are designed to make
copies of ourselves yet we're starting
to do some unnatural things for the good
of this planet wildlife management is
now being taught in universities it
sounds like an oxymoron how do you
manage something wild and yet we know
that in our parks if we don't manage the
numbers of keep a balance between prey
and predator the whole thing can
collapse well in a sense we all live in
a park now and I think that one of the
things that we have to be doing is
learning to manage our numbers because
we don't know how to produce enough
energy for all of our China's and
India's etc and all of our vehicles with
renewables yet there may be some limits
so what I am suggesting is that this is
something that we have to be considering
I'm gonna just close with one little
anecdote here or an analogy and economic
analogy and then in the time left I'll
throw it open to questions
this idea of the Ponzi scheme you know
growth growth growth economy the health
of it economy is always determined by
how much is it growing and yet as we
learned last year you know at a certain
point you know it's artificial we come
up with these strange new mechanisms to
keep thing growing and when it turns out
there's not enough people who can really
afford mortgages it will start to
collapse and yet if you hire one of
those growth growth growth economists to
consult to your corporation what are
they gonna tell you the first thing
they're gonna say is you know you got to
do to make your corporation healthy you
got to get lean you got to cut out the
fat so what happens Monday morning 25
percent of the people get this pink slip
this has all happened to somebody we
know or it's happened to some of you
unless the corporation is a humane
corporation instead of brutally bringing
itself down to size it uses attrition
every year as people move on to retire
some of them pass away it just recruits
fewer people to take their place
it gets more efficient and gradually
every year it gets more and more and
more healthy as it comes down to a more
sustainable size and frankly one way or
another that's what's gonna happen on
this planet to every species that
reaches the limits of its resource base
ultimately suffers a population crash we
managed to avoid that in the 20th
century with some very slick technology
some medical technology that helped us
live longer or eradicated a lot of
things that used to kill us out there
and agricultural technology starting
with learning how to literally increase
the amount of plant life that could grow
on this planet by instead of using the
amount of nitrogen that the sunlight and
soil can fix we dug up nitrogen out of
the ground from fossil fuels and we
create artificial nitrogen and then in
the 50s we started cleverly selecting
plants that would give much more yield
per plant and many more plants per acre
this was the Green Revolution that was
supposed to solve hunger on the planet
eradicated but Norman Borlaug the
founder that revolution also always
would say along with that we have to
control population I was just with one
of his people the other day at Cornell
University and he said unfortunately
that part got left in the dust
and as ecologists know every species
will rise to meet the available food
supply so today we've got many more
hungry people than we've ever
had before on this planet so if we just
let things go the way they're going
nature eventually is just going to come
out and hand out a bunch of pink slips
now if you're watching National
Geographic and it's you're seeing
survival of the fittest it's kind of
entertaining when it's happening to
another species other than your own but
we've come this far we've done this much
we do create so much beauty I'm not
ready to go extinct yet and I hope that
we to the fullest extent take advantage
of everything that we possibly can think
of to prolong our life so we are in
balance and not in combat with the rest
of nature including managing their own
numbers in this beautiful parkland
called earth a Peace Park I hope thank
you very much
many thanks she'll go syphilis yeah an
easy question while I look through these
is let's see you you the pub date on
your book was what three years ago four
years yeah it was July of 2007 as when
it first came out so here you are
talking about it you've obviously been
on the case you go to the various
countries where the three three
different languages are translating it
so while you're heading toward another
book which may be able to talk about
nevertheless you're having to live with
this book and this magnificent book in
the world what's what have you been
noticing since then that you're going
yeah I got nailed that one buddy and
what are the things you're noticing that
I wish I could included that or I wonder
if that refutes that part of that
chapter or you know how is it faring in
the progressing real world since the
book was done um you know I'm grateful
to say that the book has fared well I
mean a fact checked extremely hard and
you know there were there was a typo
here in there that I wish I had caught
in the original edition but in in
subsequent ones it's been fine I mean
some of the things that I really
expected to be challenged on really hard
just haven't materialized
the business press has been extremely
sympathetic to the book I mean other
than the Wall Street Journal actually do
me this great favor about calling it
this you know the latest eco bestseller
that irritatingly keeps climbing the
bestseller list or something like that
would you know I'll take publicity like
that all the time but but for the most
part people sense that okay you know
we've come to some kinds of limits that
clearly you know we can't keep growing
and growing and growing when the thing
that we're standing on the earth doesn't
grow
there's got to be a point where it will
all come collapsing and you know I got
into this book because I was very
worried about the planet I'm no longer
worried about the planet it's very clear
that the planet is gonna do just fine
it's come through worse things than us
and but the question is the planet with
us on it and you know even this
population stuff which I didn't intend
to raise at the end of the book but I
mean just to give you one example and
I've been invited twice to speak in Utah
University of Utah and Weber State which
is up and Hodgdon
and you know Mormons have the highest
reproductive rate in the in the country
so I thought okay how am I gonna talk
about this stuff and I did a little
research and what I found out was that
well this Brigham Young told everybody
you know you got to be fruitful and
multiply fill up Utah so they had
polygamy but then the United States
government was not so fond of that in
order to stay in Utah they had to give
up polygamy but that meant that men just
started impregnating the same wife over
and over again and by 1900 they had a
real crisis women were dying in
childbirth because their bodies were not
taking enough time to recover before
they got pregnant again
fortunately the Mormons really value
education and by this time there was a
whole generation of Mormon doctors and
they started consoling women to say you
know you've got to for the sake of not
just you and your family but for the
sake of our culture you have to start
spacing your births so when I talk to
these people I explained that I said you
know in some ways since you people
venerate latter-day saints and you're
not tied to these ancient liturgies like
the rest of us you may be the most
flexible people on the planet
for you
understood that you have to protect the
mother to protect your whole culture and
so now if we're talking about mother
nature maybe we've reached the point
where that's what we're gonna have to do
is really space children per family and
everyone who I had talked to I mean the
heads were not in because from augment
all the way down to Park City it's one
continuous urban strip right now and
nobody likes it I mean that's one thing
that I found that everybody has in
common in the world everybody remembers
someplace that you used to go to and it
was not too far from where you lived and
you could go out there and you could you
know you could walk or you could you
know enjoy the trees and you look at
birds shoot birds if you like to kill
birds you know whatever whatever but you
go there now and it's filled with strip
malls and housing projects and
industrial parks everybody hates that
well those two dates in in Utah I mean I
I think I signed a couple hundred books
and each one of them so what I'm finding
is that everybody senses that this has
gotten out of hand this us and yet of
course we don't want to commit mass
suicide so there seems to be room for
thinking about these things question
from David Clausen who is where
somewhere in the room I can tell what do
you think of the notion that we are in
the Anthropocene if humans had a
geologic scale impact on the world yeah
I I mean I talked about it and the
in the book wee-ooo
one example I give is is Africa I mean
at one point I go back to Africa to talk
about you know why did we evolve in the
first place and you know it turns out
that about 8 million years ago or so the
world was locked in ice ages where so
much of the moisture was you was was in
ice that even though Africa wasn't
covered Africa had a drought and the
forest just became
instead of being connected all the way
across
Africa's midriff there were just pockets
of it and the mutual ancestor that we
share with chimpanzees I mean there was
literally less and less space for these
things to exist so you know we think
often times you know we evolved to have
this great vision we climbed out of the
trees and walked out from the savanna to
go across the horizon I mean the fact
was there was a there was a fight to see
who got to have those diminishing
resources and we were the losers or our
ancestors the chimpanzees are still up
there because but but we literally had
to go out in the savanna to learn to
stand on our own two feet so we could
see lions bounding a Addison and today
just what we have done to Africa and
mowing down so much forest and
converting it to farmland we've
basically recreated that situation
there's no ice age going on but the
pockets of where chimpanzees now live
are smaller and smaller and smaller and
and I go visit it in fact I go and talk
to some chimpanzees in the wild I'm not
sure they understood what I was saying
but man I could see it in their eyes
they they they know what they're up
against well it's the Revenge of the the
sapiens you finally got back at those
nasty chimpanzees maybe that's it
I'll teach them to treat us unkind I
mean this is such a long now subject no
long now talk that I can't resist asking
you the question that you know we've got
three of the major engineers and a
10,000 year clock working away here
looking at the right materials the right
mechanism is the right place to park
inside a desert Mound all that kind of
stuff what is a 10,000 your clock mean
to you if anything well first of all
taking the long view is really important
I mean you know I I do actually find it
comforting to realize that in the long
run life is going to be okay you know
I'm not a creationist as I'm sure you've
gathered but I really understand the ah
that those people feel for the power of
life and you know they attributed to a
higher power you know there's no proof
that it is or isn't really but but but
what does interest me about you know the
going 10,000 years is first of all the
hope implicit that we might mm-hm it
might be meaningful to us and second
some of the delicious problems that it
raises and at one point I talked about
whip and you do in your book to this
place where we are now bearing waste
from manufacture of military uses of
nuclear materials and the same guy john
Lomborg who designed this packet that's
off on the Viking spacecraft was hired
by whip to to talk about how do we warn
the future that we're burying this stuff
down there because language mutates
affect like every 500 years it's it's I
mean you try to talk to someone was
speaking English 500 years ago yeah we
can't understand each other or like
those Norwegians who got isolated in
Iceland they call that ancient Norse
Icelandic now and Norwegians can't
understand them so you know so they came
up with all these symbols and things
like that to warn the future
and they've got to design it hasn't been
built yet but but a lot of them are all
these symbols with plaques and it's some
of them gonna be buried so if they dig
down someone from the future digs down
there I mean to me you see all these
plaques and things like that it's just
so something interesting is here
you know the idea is that it's mostly a
warning sign they also have warnings up
there in like seven languages that they
think might last so long as Navajos one
of them you know it's the fact is we
can't predict the future I mean that's
one of the most wonderful things about
culture things change all the time is so
many of the technologies you know the
Columbian World's Fair in 1993 that
predicted what was going to happen
they missed television they missed
computers you know just you know we
don't know what's gonna happen but we
have to be thinking in those terms
because the idea of posterity is one of
the things that keeps us going okay
here's a challenging question from Linda
it says what are your thoughts about
genetic modification can nature come
back and quotes after it's been genetic
its genetic coding has fundamentally
changed there's a portion in my book
where I talk about ozone depletion and
[Music]
what I learned when I understand and
Antarctica talking to ozone scientists
is that the fact is nature is has always
been undergoing genetic modification and
a lot of it's from radioactivity of one
sort or another either the background
radioactivity in the Earth's crust or
ultraviolet radiation which is not as
intense as but still it has been subtly
changing us genetic modification is
constantly taking place and the whole
thing we can't preserve the ecosystem we
can't spray plastic on it it would be a
museum
peace at that point change and evolution
is just a constant process and evolution
is caused by a number of things
selection for changing environmental
situations for new competitors who show
up and also because radiation either if
it's coming from above or it's coming
from below it's just part of the picture
you know if we start tinkering with
genes here as we're already starting to
do some of them I think most of them are
gonna be fairly benign but something
might escape I don't know I guess we'll
find out there's you know we don't have
a control group an experimental group
we're all part of it hey that's an
imponderable but it's already going it's
on underway yeah it's all in the
experiment without a control you know
Alexander Rose s why do you think we
glorify feeling species like the panda
yet denigrate flourishing ones like the
raccoon Oh God
you know I mean I find them both equally
cute but I mean very few of us had a
teddy raccoon
a lot of us had teddy bears that look
like pandas so that's one of them it's
one of the reasons for pandas but you
know frankly when something starts to
disappear on us you know this happens in
all phases of life you don't know what
you got till it's gone and
and we do sense that some of these
species that are so vivid and when they
start to go not only do we miss them but
we go oops what's next
I don't know I mean one of the things
that I'm doing my research right now for
my next book it's trying to figure out
are there any species out there that as
I mentioned before that you know if we
pushed one too many species off the
planet is there something that we could
not do without and we would be gone
what's your candidate for that as you do
the research well you know the first
thing that comes to my mind is
pollinators I live in New England we're
having a bat crash now you all heard
about the bee crash that has been going
on birds they also help pollinate and
species mning numbers of songbirds and a
lot of this has to do with this
agricultural technology I mean basically
agricultural technology has involved
creating some amazing plants but we have
to force-feed the land with chemicals
either to grow them faster or to protect
them out there and a lot of those things
are killing migrating birds you know
there's a lot of things that we eat like
grains itself pollinate so I guess we
wouldn't die but I mean just think of
all the things that come out of
flowering plants fruit goodbye fruit you
know that would be you know that would
be really scary I don't know the answer
yeah in fact I haven't found scientists
who do know but I'm talking to lots of
them all over the place I mean certainly
there's some microbes within us that if
they weren't there don't know this is
one question of a set of them presumably
in probably the audience would love to
hear what the general point if the
direction of the book is if you want to
talk about oh well I'd like to know
because I don't think we do know
what would be an optimum number of human
means I mean what what is the carrying
capacity of the planet how many of us
could fit on here with this planet
without destabilizing the eco system to
the point that it becomes the wild card
that it's becoming of course it's a very
complex question at what level of
consumption you know some people consume
very little compared to some of us here
in the United States so you know I have
to touch that base but I'm also thinking
ok let's say a European level of
consumption not as extravagant as as a
US but certainly much more comfortable
than a lot of people on the planet so is
there a way that we can find out really
what that optimum number is and what
does stabilized environment mean does
this mean pushing no more species off
the planet or just preserving the ones
that are essential to us how can we tell
you know Peter Ward up in Washington and
wrote a book in which he talked about he
envisioned the future in the year 3000
and the only other species besides us
are some interesting chickens and cows
you know domesticate variations of other
domesticated creatures
he admitted there'd be some vermin and
some there'd be snakes that could fly in
rats that were very adaptive and stuff
like that but but basically it would be
a very thin ecosystem out there the
whole world would be a big barnyard
interesting vision but I'm trying to
test out to find out it well the Opera
Green had a question are there examples
of societies or countries that are
successfully shrinking their population
that sort of match what you've been
raising here yeah you know I mentioned
two of them Italy and Iran their
populations have it's interesting as
Italy as inadvertent I mean they've got
this Pope you know and this guy
Berlusconi who's really they're
literally trying to bribe women to have
more babies you know
offering incentives and women are just
doing you know what they are doing which
is you know going to school and and look
how bad a place is Italy right now we
paid good money to go there and hang out
because it's fun you know you know it
may be a model in you know Iran was you
know yes a very fundamentalist country
and maybe a lot of you don't want to
live in fundamentalist countries I don't
myself but they within the framework of
their religion they came up with a way
of bringing their numbers down to a much
more sensible level unfortunately
someone's trying to undo that right now
so you know there are some other
examples of Tunisia has had for a long
time
good family planning Indonesia has been
one of the most explosive countries on
earth and now there's billboards all
over saying to maybe just enough so
they're they're starting to get it you
know their comment I made about the
Green Revolution by the way think about
this the places where it was developed
as Mexico the places where it was first
tried out on big scales India and
Pakistan Mexico in case anybody hasn't
noticed can't feed employ house all of
its people and so a lot of them are
trying to get into this country now
India is about to surpass China within
the next 15 years is the most populous
country on Earth and the fastest-growing
country on the planet right now is
Pakistan which i think is something we
should all be a little concerned about
question from Susan will be the last
question okay do many readers tell you
this is an optimistic book my favorite
comments and I've seen this in some
reviews
the Toronto Globe and Mail I remember
called the book the very DNA of hope and
Louise Erdrich a lot of you know her her
novels wonderful wonderful writer I mean
it paid me an enormous compliment by
saying that this book was simultaneously
one of the most harrowing and hopeful
books she had ever read about the
environment I mean the harrowing part is
that by extracting the human beings and
seeing what nature would have to contend
with what we leave behind is sort of an
reverse way of looking at what our
impact has been up until right now and
it is formidable obviously but the
hopeful part is that not only does
nature bounce back rather amazingly and
surprisingly effectively and beautifully
you know I noticed in your book you
mentioned some of the buffer zones and
at one point I talked about what was
once called the most contaminated place
on the planet it's kind of a euphemism
because there's lots of contenders but
it's it was Rocky Mountain Arsenal where
we used to make nerve gas during World
War two and then later became
fertilizers plant and there was a lake
there that ducks and geese would land on
it and they'd be dead within minutes it
was so contaminated and the the aluminum
boat that they would roll out there to
collect the dark carcasses they would
have to replace it every month because
the bottom would carota
and yet they've drained the lake your
tax dollars in mind you know and they've
done some mitigation but mainly you know
they're not doing that stuff in this
area maybe it is now one of the biggest
prairie dog villages which has attracted
some of the the biggest populations of
bald eagles it's now a National Wildlife
Refuge at the end of my book in the
chapter about the sea I talked about the
place where we used to burn nerve gas
and also test plutonium weapons Johnston
at all on the far end of of Hawaii and
that is also now National Wildlife
Refuge the fact is we got terrible
problems on this planet
outside it's still beautiful and we've
got ravaged and banged as it's been we
have this beautiful baseline today's
baseline that if we just lighten up a
little bit
life will do magical on spiring things
and if you you know if it inspires
religion in you that's fine whatever it
inspires in you you know I don't care
whether you're a fundamentalist or a
secularist if we all realize that the
environment is something that we have in
common you know but let me just say one
less thing in clothing it closings and
say I've just reminded myself of it at
the end of the book I very briefly touch
on religion in the book could have been
enormous if I would have gone into all
of this but I realized that some readers
would have felt that I had left
something unanswered if I didn't touch
base with religious because two of the
world's biggest religions Islam and
Christianity believe there's no such
thing as a world without us because the
world was made for us and once we're
we're gone you know it's over so I
talked to some religious leaders and one
just about their ideas of what would
happen and and one of the things that it
was very very struck by was that in
three very very different fundamentalist
situations a korean buddhist monk an
evangelical christian leader in this
country and a Muslim cleric and Istanbul
and I've just returned from research
trip to Palestine in Israel and I heard
this from a Hasidic rabbi as well I mean
it's almost the identical thing all of
these people believe the world is coming
to an end either they're waiting for a
messiah to come relson or in the case of
the Buddhists it's gonna start over
again but but they do believe that the
world is coming to an end and when I
asked him when each of them said in in
in in the book the Muslim cleric
is the one I quote you know ah that's
the thing we don't know only God knows
but while we are still here just as we
have an obligation to keep our bodies
pure and uncontaminated to be channels
for prayer and to keep our houses of
worship beautiful places to welcome the
spirit we also have an obligation to
keep this planet as much as possible the
way that God gave it to us and that just
amazed me because that means no matter
if you are a fundamentalist or an
atheist or a scientist or whatever there
is one thing that we all share and that
is this planet and you remember those
two koreas if they did this wonderful
thing for the ecosystem for the world by
creating an International Peace Park
inevitably they would come closer to
each other - and maybe it would really
bring some real peace to them well
frankly we all live in the DMZ this is
our DMZ and if we all do whatever it
takes to keep this a livable place for
whatever our reasons be they religious
or be they scientific or just be the
ethical be they personal
we've all got this opportunity not only
to save the one thing that we all share
but perhaps to bring ourselves a little
closer and finally find that peace that
hasn't been eluding us for so long
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]